motivation and really is part of the
great reset is this
this move towards technocratic global
tyranny
whose primary purpose is to transfer the
vast majority of the wealth and the
assets
from everyone else to them it's a wealth
transfer
move is what it is it's just that people
aren't aware of it and they couldn't
they don't even believe it so why are
they looking for it and
told something completely well here
that's that's the key element
told something how are we told something
right that's
that's the key question we're told
something typically and in most
cases through the conventional
mainstream
media kind of think about this
if you know and we can go into vaccine i
mean i'm not an expert on it and i
haven't studied it deeply but i know the
i can know the broad strokes so if you
believe
that people who are promoting and
supporting this vaccine are authentic
and sincere and and critically believe
that it's going to end this pandemic
then why and we're getting into some of
these other questions that you had
earlier
then you would think they would allow
free
discussion of the pros and cons because
there is no way in the world it is
physically impossible that you could
give an informed
consent to any therapeutic intervention
unless you know both sides
if you're only told one side how could
it be informed consent it's can't be
it's impossible
it's it's essentially propaganda and
that's what they've done
i think though yeah like i
an alternative could be that the people
who are in charge who truly believe the
vaccine is the answer believe that the
general public are too stupid to make
their own decisions
and therefore aren't letting them make
their own decisions
because they're doing it for their
greater good and they're right that
could be their
my guess is that's what they tell
themselves that's your justification but
if you like if you go
higher and you look at it objectively
and it's hard to look at this
objectively because you know there's so
much emotion involved
but if you look at it objectively you
have to realize that you
it is as i said it's impossible to have
informed consent unless you understand
both sides and it's totally suppressed
it
anything anything that even comes close
to hinting
of casting the disparaging vaccines and
disparaging life
is immediately removed immediately
censored
entirely whole platforms all many sites
have been taken down
including bobby kennedy's who's a you
know he's pretty much vaccine neutral i
mean
even though he appears to be an
anti-back person he's
if they work fine he he's vaccinated his
family he's not opposed to them
but that you've got to do with common
sense because these
companies these corporations these
multinational corporations that are
making
these vaccines like pfizer being the
classic example
and johnson and johnson they're criminal
entities they've been
they've been convicted of crimes in the
past paid
billions and billions of dollars in
fines for breaking the law
so why would anyone seriously consider
trusting these companies when they have
a history
and the history isn't good so another
view that's out there is
that this is a plan for the elite to
take over
given how hard this has been on poor
people and jobs
that we're getting forced into
vaccinations it's being run by the
government the pharmaceutical and the
elite
it's making the rich richer it's taking
away of freedoms if we don't get the
vaccine
how do you feel about that theory well i
think that's a pretty bad theory because
the poor are suffering the most from the
virus if you are
a person who lives in a crowded house
who cannot socially distance i mean the
people are getting crushed by this are
prisoners who don't have access to
vaccines
um people who have to show up at their
job as a bus driver regardless i mean
those people
um want the vaccine as as much or more
than the rich but you see the rich kind
of cutting in line trying to get it
faster
because no one wants to get sick i mean
even trump apparently got the vaccine
on the dl like he didn't announce it he
went and got like inoculated
you know it's like you want to be
protected i mean remember the thing
about vaccines
is that they allow you like you you can
teach a man to fish
but you know if if it or you can give
him fish if if you can fish for yourself
you're going to be able to eat many
meals and i don't have to like catch
your fish for you
your immune system is a great a great
amazing uh complex beautiful like
symphony orchestra of evolution
that defends your body against all kinds
of things like
it's like got a cia an fbi beat cops
it's got a whole bunch of different
cells that do different jobs
and a vaccine just gives it a mug shot
of hey here's the bad guy
look out for this dude and so it can
make its own selves to fight it so you
don't need a pharmaceutical company
giving you recombinant antibodies in a
hospital bed and billing you
you know thousands and thousands of
dollars like
a vaccine enables your body's own native
intelligence to fight
um diseases the same way you would fight
the diseases if you were naturally
infected and came up with the best
immune response
as far as i know this is the very first
mrna vaccine in people but let me
demystify
why mrna vaccines are so um from a
regulatory standpoint which means and
the reason those regulations like the
fda is one of the best organizations
like as far as protecting your health
and watching out for like americans like
they are very very conservative
about what they will approve for use in
humans um
so much so that the big pharma companies
aren't universally happy about it you
know but they
they do have to play by the rules to get
their vaccines and their diagnostic
tests
and any therapy approved so this this
vaccine is
emergency youth authorized it's not a
formally approved therapy
or a vac it's not really a therapy it's
a vaccine okay
the thing to know is that mrna is um
something that our cells make all the
time to it's like it's your ram if
you're a computer if you're
new if your dna code or your genetic
code is your uh
hard drive the the the rna that's
translated is like the temporary message
and so rna always breaks down it's not
there forever but it can tell your
little you have little machines in your
cells every single one of your
living cells has little machines in it
called ribosomes that translate the
genetic code
and what viruses do is hijack them they
take over the cell and they turn it into
a virus factory
this this rna is basically looks a lot
like the rna our own cells make
and what's exciting about it is it
doesn't have much else in it so there's
just the way to get it
across the cell membrane it's called a
lipid nanoparticle it's basically
thing that's stuff that looks like stuff
that already is around our cells and
bodies
but it gets the message across the
membrane and makes just one viral
protein
so it's so simple from a regulatory
standpoint
they do have to test it and make sure
it's safe but when you take a lot of
other vaccines
they're much more complicated they have
like a replicating virus in them that's
weakened and passage in cell culture it
has a whole bunch of viral proteins it's
making
and it was like grown in cells which you
know maybe were made like people object
to some of these cells because they were
made in the 1970s from like an aborted
uh fetus or something uh or a cancer
cell line or something that
or a chicken embryo and people are kind
of freaked out by that this
mrna is just purely made from the same
biochemicals that make up our bodies
like it's
it's our own genetic code just like the
virus does
use our genetic code against us the mrna
flips on the virus
and and says okay cool we're just going
to take out the one thing that we need
to defend our
to know about to defend our bodies from
kova 19 and we're going to
give you the secret message of what you
need to know here's the mug shot of the
bad guy
in mrna forum